you
welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from Google Cloud roasting webinars
every Tuesday my name is John Barris and
I'll be talking about cloud CPUs you can
ask questions anytime on the platform
when we have Googlers on standby to
answer them so today I'll be joined with
by Jax
can you talk by Zack Stone the product
manager at tense flow and cloud tea
views from the Google brain team so I
want to talk a little bit about machine
learning and cloud tea views and new
opportunities that are available now due
to machine learning and also the central
computational challenge related to
machine learning and what we're doing
about it so I have a couple of examples
I'd like to mention first you know
digital cameras were created 40 to 45
years ago and then about 20 years ago
they became popular even for consumers
and if you had a digital camera 20 years
ago you might have been taking pictures
taking the memory card out of the camera
and sticking in your computer and just
saving the pictures on your hard drive
and if you wanted to find a picture from
an event or of a particular person you
had to kind of either have good
organizational skills of how to keep
track of photos on your computer or you
could remember when the picture was
taking kind of search by date and try to
find that photo well things have changed
a lot nowadays I keep my pictures on
Google photos and if I want to find for
instance a picture of the Golden Gate
Bridge or the Eiffel Tower I can just
type in Golden Gate Bridge your Eiffel
Tower into the search bar and because
Google photos has used machine learning
tools to identify objects in those
photos it can call up all the pictures
that I've taken to the Golden Gate
Bridge or the Eiffel Tower and present
them to me so that I can go through them
very quickly it's made my life so much
easier in fact if I have a friend that
I'd like to find a picture of if I've
already tagged that friend in one photo
I can easily find that friend and many
other photos as well so that's super
convenient so that's an example of how
consumers can save time using machine
learning but perhaps you'd be interested
in another example that are that is good
for enterprises and I'm thinking about
automobile manufacturing lines it turns
out that when an automobile
manufacturing line goes down it costs
about twenty-two thousand dollars a
minute and lost revenue
or in costs and that's up more than a
million dollars an hour and so having a
machine fail on that manufacturing line
is actually quite expensive and so it's
much better if the company can identify
when the machine might fail and then
schedule a maintenance repair to that
machine during a time when the line is
down already for maintenance and so what
a company might do in that case is fit
those machines with sensors maybe audio
sensors pressure temperature vibration
or anything like that
and then look at that data and use
machine learning and use the computers
to identify patterns in that data that
might indicate when a machine might be
ready for maintenance and by doing that
they can schedule the maintenance on the
machine instead of having the machine
fail at an inopportune time so here's
some other examples too for that for
instance the Google Arts and Culture app
that runs on your phone can use a selfie
and identify a picture or a drawing by a
famous artist that most closely matches
your selfie so our colleagues at eesh
did this here and hitch turns out he
looked most like Chuck Berry in this
drawing by Gilbert Shelton there's
another example that's very useful when
you're traveling if you have if you're
in a foreign country and you can't read
the language that's presented on it on a
street sign or a menu you can actually
use the camera to take a picture of that
menu and then Google uses machine
learning to identify the text convert
that text to machine readable format
convert them to a language we understand
and insert that language in the text
that we can read in the same place on
the on the image so that we can read a
menu even in a foreign language it's
incredibly convenient now here's another
example of making life easier is smart
reply in inbox who are when a piece of
mail comes in instead of having to type
with your thumbs the whole response
smart reply offers a few responses that
might be appropriate for this message
and you can just press a button and then
that response is inserted into the email
then you can add your own comments and
send it off it's a nice time saver now
it turns out that making all this
machine learning work effectively and
quickly requires a substantial amount of
computation power because of the
increasing complexity of machine learn
models are in use so for instance image
recognition and object detection models
that are run for on images often if 50
or 100 or even more layers and billions
of neurons that can be activated by the
information coming in to the model so in
this example you can see the input layer
at the bottom
perhaps that input layer is taking the
data from the machines that have been
instrumented in a manufacturing line and
neurons are activated based on the input
data and then that information activates
additional neurons in layers above that
until finally the final output layer
might only have two settings either
needs maintenance soon or doesn't need
maintenance soon and so that's an
example of kind of how the neurons work
in a machine learning model now what
we're finding is that current solutions
haven't provided enterprises with enough
computing power and recent AI advances
are almost all attributable to advances
in compute our and in fact we surveyed
attendees at a recent tensorflow event
and found that most of them felt like
their compute power was inadequate they
needed much more computational power so
our mission at Google is to democratize
AI make it available both through
services and infrastructure making
accessible fast and useful for
enterprises and developers we have over
10,000 customers taken advantage of our
AI solutions we've launched 12 products
last year with dozens of features
related to a AI and we have over 30
cloudy AI partners and in fact we have
over a million Kaggle members that are
using AI on our platform so now here to
tell you more about cloud T P uses axe
stone Zak thanks John hi everyone I'm
really excited to talk to you today
about cloud GPUs as you can see here
this cloud CPU board is the latest
offering in Google cloud and it's
Google's second generation machine
learning accelerator so as a product
manager for tensorflow
one thing that john mentioned earlier is
that most tensorflow users who are
working with state-of-the-art deep
neural networks are hungry for more
compute and tensorflow it's open source
it's free it
across a huge variety of different
platforms from state-of-the-art CPUs to
GPUs to cloud CPUs and on to mobile and
embedded devices so across all those
devices were committed to tensorflow
providing fantastic performance today
we're focusing on this cloud GPU this
new addition to the lineup in google
cloud so what's special about this
second-generation TPU well first of all
on the reference workloads that we've
open-source this provides differentiated
performance per dollar we think this is
a really economical way to get work done
especially on some of these incredibly
intense computational challenges
associated with state of the art machine
learning systems each board delivers up
to 180 teraflops per device which is a
lot if you've ever built a system
yourself and by hosting these in cloud
you can scale up and scale down easily
as your needs change instead of having
to put in the capital and expertise and
data center cooling and power and so
forth to build a cluster like this and
manage it yourself right now these cloud
TPS architected for tensorflow so you
can program them with tensor flows
high-level api's instead of having to do
bespoke supercomputer programming as you
might have in a previous era let me tell
you a little bit more about the
motivation behind these cloud GPUs first
of all it's really important to be able
to train and run complex machine
learning models faster as John mentioned
one of the trends that we've observed
over the past several decades really but
especially over the past five years is
that increasing computational power and
scale of these models has led to much
higher accuracy and unlocked new
applications that just wouldn't have
been feasible previously also we find
that it's really important here at
Google and elsewhere across the world to
improve the productivity of machine
learning teams when you are training
machine learning model it's common to
wait for hours or days or even in some
cases weeks for the model to converge
and be ready to deploy in production
that's like waiting weeks for your code
to compile and so what we're trying to
do both with tensorflow across all
platforms and then this cloud CPUs is to
reduce that time to hours and perhaps
some day to minutes so people can
iterate faster and be more
octave finally as I mentioned earlier
it's really valuable to be able to scale
up and down easily with on-demand
machine learning infrastructure in the
cloud you don't have to fight with
provisioning machines configuring
drivers you can just connect your
virtual machine to a cloud TP you start
running open-source tensorflow and train
faster than ever before let me say a
little bit more about ml teams of ML
engineers ml researchers data scientists
one thing that you're probably aware is
we certainly are here is that the talent
to build these state-of-the-art machine
learning models is in very high demand
right now and very scarce and so it's
really important for the people that you
have in your organization who have the
strongest expertise in this domain to be
able to move as quickly as possible and
so with these higher performance
accelerators and great high level
software on top of them you can enable
your ml teams to accomplish a lot more
than they could otherwise furthermore
I'd like to emphasize as I mentioned
before that this is now the second in a
whole line of machine learning
accelerators that Google has developed
in-house we had our first generation
tensor processing unit that was
optimized for inference and used
internally this is the second generation
tensor processing unit built into a
cloud CPU board and even into larger
systems that I'll tell you about in a
minute so every time you run a search
your search results are ranked in
conjunction with some of these tensor
processing units here at Google when you
use Google photos as John mentioned
earlier some of the organization of
those photos is facilitated with these
tensor processing units and and across
many other Google products you're
interacting with these accelerators
every day and now you have the
opportunity to incorporate the same
accelerators into your own businesses
through Google cloud one thing that
we're trying to do is to make it easy
for people to get started with cloud
type views and the way that we're
approaching that is by open sourcing
reference workloads that are optimized
and ready to go on these cloud Tipu's
initially we've concentrated on a few
categories of reference workloads on
visual recognition so image
classification these are models
like ResNet fifty or inception or for
lower resource devices mobile net and
squeeze net and this is really useful if
you have an object sort of centered in a
frame you know where you're looking and
you need to tell is this a cat or is it
a dog is this you know a vehicle in this
closed crop of an image or is it
pavement right for an autonomous driving
application so we have a lot of models
there that are ready to go well
optimized and we're continuing to
improve their performance further over
time secondly we've got reference models
in machine translation and language
modeling these are built around this
state-of-the-art transformer model
that's part of the open source tensor
two tensor library and transformers been
really useful for both machine
translation from one language to another
also for language modeling where you're
trying to predict the next word in a
sentence as you might if you're building
a messaging app and you want to make it
easier for people to input messages to
one another but transformer is actually
more general and useful for other
sequence to sequence problems as well
finally related to the the small image
visual classification I mentioned
earlier we've got a reference model for
object detection called retina net so
this is useful if you don't have a small
crop but instead you're searching for
small objects in a large field of view
like you might for autonomous driving
but also for medical imaging you might
need to look for regions of an image
that medical practitioner should focus
on in a large scan that may be many
megapixels and so retina net might be a
useful starting point if you're
interested in those sorts of
applications just to give you a sense of
how broad the application domains are
even with these building blocks of these
reference workloads that I mentioned
earlier I'd like to call out a few other
applications one that's quite surprising
is genetic variant calling so when
you're sequencing a genome there's this
final step when you're reconstructing
the sequence where you need to call
variants you need to decide ok the reads
are suggesting that there's a there's a
base pair modified here is that base
pair really modified or not is this is
this a real variant or not and so a team
here at Google has developed an
algorithm called deep variant that
recasts this problem that
additionaly takes hours or days on a
cluster of CPUs as an image recognition
problem that you can now run on these
state-of-the-art machine learning
accelerators whether GPUs or TP use and
so we think this this dramatically
speeds up the process and we think this
will make genetic sequencing faster and
a lot more affordable to be used in many
new ways as I mentioned before
autonomous vehicles are really important
domain for visual recognition and object
detection and there are many aspects to
that problem there's some teams that are
considering running machine perception
on vehicles detecting pedestrians and
street signs and road markings and
obstacles and so forth those are all
visual perception problems but also
visual recognition and processing is
valuable for the mapping that often goes
on beforehand before the vehicles even
go out on the road you need to
understand the world in great detail so
they have an accurate map of where they
can drive and not drive and finally
obviously there's a huge amount of
opportunity in retail retailers
everywhere are experimenting with new
kinds of customer experiences checkout
experiences in-store experiences
shopping experiences online and all of
these experiences tend to be highly
visual and require detailed
understanding of what's present in an
image in a scene in a live video stream
and so we think these these
state-of-the-art cloud GPUs are going to
be helpful for rapid prototyping and
then deployment of these new retail
experiences so I mentioned earlier that
these cloud GPUs on the left are the
ones that are available today in beta
and Google cloud but they're also
designed to be connected together into
even larger systems like the TPU pod
that you can see over on the right now
these pods are amazing this has a total
of 256 of these TPU chips 64 boards and
can deliver up to 11 and a half pedda
flops of computing performance for a
single machine learning problem and if
you want to train a model in half an
hour instead of in days and these are
coming to cloud later this year we think
these cloud TPU pods are going to
provide a great solution for Polk's
folks who are starting their development
now on cloud GPUs with no code changes
to then scale up by more than an order
of magnitude without any code changes to
law as long as you can tolerate larger
batch sizes so one thing that we've
announced recently is that our own
internal experiments have shown that you
can take a model that would train in
about a day on one of these boards in a
certain configuration and scale that all
the way down to thirty minutes training
on a cloud TPU pod and we're continuing
to optimize these systems further so
we're looking forward to bringing these
to Google cloud so you can enjoy them as
well so if you want to get started since
a demand is intense we ask that you
visit the page here cloud google.com
slash TPU and request quota and we're
doing our best to process those quota
requests as quickly as we can thank you
very much we'll be taking questions in
just a moment we'll be right back after
a minute break thanks again
you
welcome back we have a few questions
we'd like to answer so we'll mention the
question then give the answer first of
all someone said I've applied for TPU
quota during Alpha and again at beta and
I haven't heard anything when will I get
a chance to try cloudy fuse well I have
to say they've been very popular we just
ask for your patience you'll get a
chance soon but thanks for for your
patience and waiting
totally again we wish we could give
these to everyone right now so we're
trying as hard as we can there's a
second question here I saw an article
indicating the cost of training on GPUs
is much more expensive compared to
Nvidia volta GPUs so while we won't make
direct comparisons today one thing that
we'd encourage you when you get access
to cloud GPUs is to run benchmarks
yourself on your own workloads it's
actually really subtle to run a
benchmark accurately you need to decide
are you processing real data and
measuring the full performance of your
input pipeline are you running on
synthetic data are you testing that the
model converges all the way to the right
accuracy as we do with our reference
workloads are you just looking at the
step time performance we're pretty
confident that we offer differentiated
performance per dollar for our reference
workloads and we're already starting to
see some of our early users running
their own benchmarks and talking about
them online so the performance will
definitely be different from one
workload to another and it's really
important for you to run your own
experiments to decide what accelerator
works for you the important thing to
recognize is that Google clouds goal is
to offer the best experience for machine
learning across all workloads and that
means we're hosting the state-of-the-art
CPUs state of the art GPUs and state of
the art cloud GPUs so we don't want this
to be an either-or kind of a thing you
should be able to test on all of the
state-of-the-art machine learning
platforms and on a workload by workload
basis figure out which ones are most
appropriate for you ok the next question
is can I use PI torch cafe or other
frameworks for programming GPUs so today
we offer tensorflow for program GPUs and
that's so that's the only thing that's
available right now we've heard people
request pie charts and cafe we don't
have a solution for you today but I'd
say stay stay in in tune you know and if
we have anything to
offer will let you know but today it's
tensorflow only great there's a question
here can I do inference on TPS or only
training so that's a great question
so TP use support training and inference
at the moment in bata the best support
is we spend a lot of time optimizing
training we've also got some early
support for batch inference if you have
some huge corpus of images let's say
that you need to process with a trained
model that's something you can do today
we are working on more optimizations
over time to support low latency
inference but we wouldn't recommend that
right now in production okay the next
question is this is a second generation
of TPU as act mentioned earlier will
there be a third generation and can you
tell us anything about it well we gue
Google Cloud has not announced anything
about future generations of TPU so we
don't have anything to say about that
right now right all I can comment is
that broadly speaking hardware
architecture is interesting again so
there's a whole variety of new hardware
platforms that are becoming available
both here and elsewhere let's see if we
have any other questions yeah we don't
have any other questions so stay tuned
for the next session showcase your data
stories online with Google Data studio
thanks for hanging in we appreciate it